Avery Kim: Today’s focus: search relevance tuning.
Avery Kim: Any blockers from last time?
Avery Kim: Let’s aim for a concrete owner and rollout plan.
Jordan Patel: We’ll need QA test cases listed on search relevance tuning.
Avery Kim: From QA perspective, Security review is likely.
Noah Williams: UX needs a final pass on search relevance tuning.
Jordan Patel: Let’s not block on search relevance tuning; ship a thin slice.
Noah Williams: I propose we split search relevance tuning into two subtasks.
Riley Chen: Let’s not block on search relevance tuning; ship a thin slice.
Noah Williams: Let’s not block on search relevance tuning; parallelize testing.
Riley Chen: I propose we split search relevance tuning into two subtasks.
Noah Williams: Action: create test plan.
Avery Kim: Let’s not block on search relevance tuning; ship a thin slice.
Riley Chen: Infra-wise, We will stage it behind a feature flag.
Samira López: Action: create test plan.
Samira López: I propose we split search relevance tuning into two subtasks.
Avery Kim: I think we split search relevance tuning into two subtasks.
Riley Chen: My take is we split search relevance tuning into two subtasks.
Samira López: Coordinate with SRE for rollout on search relevance tuning.
Jordan Patel: I propose we split search relevance tuning into two subtasks.
Jordan Patel: Risk: flaky tests for search relevance tuning.
Riley Chen: My take is we split search relevance tuning into two subtasks.
Samira López: I think we split search relevance tuning into two subtasks.
Noah Williams: Action: create test plan.
Noah Williams: Any risks we’re missing? on search relevance tuning.
Avery Kim: Let’s not block on search relevance tuning; parallelize testing.
Samira López: I think we split search relevance tuning into two subtasks.
Samira López: Action: book design review.
Jordan Patel: From design side, Security review is likely.
Avery Kim: Action: set up dashboards.
Priya Singh: Action: book design review.
Riley Chen: Let’s not block on search relevance tuning; start with a spike.
Samira López: Risk: data migration for search relevance tuning.
Noah Williams: From QA perspective, Specifically for search relevance tuning.
Noah Williams: Infra-wise, Tests should cover unhappy paths.
Priya Singh: Action: create test plan.
Noah Williams: Let’s not block on search relevance tuning; start with a spike.
Jordan Patel: Let’s clarify acceptance criteria on search relevance tuning.
Priya Singh: My take is we split search relevance tuning into two subtasks.
Priya Singh: Let’s not block on search relevance tuning; ship a thin slice.
Jordan Patel: Action: create test plan.
Avery Kim: Action: set up dashboards.
Samira López: I think we split search relevance tuning into two subtasks.
Jordan Patel: Quick update on the scope on search relevance tuning.
Samira López: Let’s not block on search relevance tuning; ship a thin slice.
Priya Singh: Okay, who can take ownership?
Avery Kim: Let’s finalize target date in Jira after this.
Samira López: We’ll review outcomes in the next standup.